[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone its Alicia Malone welcome to
another episode of fandango's indie
movie guides the show where I guide you
through the smaller films that are
playing in theaters the ones that nobody
else is talking about but are worth
watching let's start with a film called
lost in Paris before my Aunt Martha DFG
owner help after 48 years living in
Paris they wanted to return old people's
homes ridiculous ammonia ACS you've
always wanted to go to Paris this is so
wonderful it does the burlesque duo
called Abel and Gordon he is Dominique
Abel and she is Fiona Gordon together
they create these wonderful movies which
really are homogeneous to the slapstick
comedies with old Buster Keaton Charlie
Chaplin those kind of movies that just
don't exist anymore
her art is played by the late Emanuele
Revo this is such a great movie for her
last film meanwhile there's this
homeless guy who finds her bag and
decides to spend her money and wear her
clothes and the two end up having dinner
at the same place when coincidences and
mayhem and madness abound
[Music]
it's just a wholesome comedy with some
very funny visual gags and I love the
comedy and a romance about two very
awkward people probably because I'm
pretty awkward myself I absolutely
adored lost in Paris and make sure you
try to find it if it's playing near you
a movie that was actually out last week
but I wanted to tell you about it is
called Megan levy or Megan levy if you
are in America
it's based on a true story and stars
kate mara as a young Marine corporal who
ends up having to look after the canine
unit she comes across his dog Rex who is
very aggressive she forms a bond with
him becomes this great trainer and the
two really work to heal each other you
think I'm afraid of you
lay down Rex lay down
yeah that might sound cheesy and it kind
of is it's a little bit manipulative in
terms of the way it goes to your emotion
but damn it's good at it I mean take
your tissues to this one I'm a sucker
for any movie about animals and this
really shows another side to war one
that you don't see very often all the
tissues all the tissues dressing changes
classifications that I can adopt him
when you get back
they aren't it they're worried
this is directed by Gabriela
Cowperthwaite who was the state director
behind blackfish that documentary from a
couple of years ago about see well so
obviously she has a great affinity for
animals and that really shines through
here look you see directs if you were
here thanks for teaching me what
weathers now to another film which has a
title which is a woman's name beginning
with M it's also directed by a woman it
is morally based on a true story and it
serves Sally Hawkins I sold the house ma
market to me I'd look after it you can't
look after you I get a job or something
my job which I'm doing illegal no she
plays a woman called Morty who has a
horrible arthritis condition she's been
disabled since she was very very young
and Jan's up getting a job as a
housekeeper for the very gruff Everett
played by ethan hawke there's me and
dogs some chickens then you do you want
me here and drunk it could go walk out
right now do you could make berries in
the wall I'm aunt LUKS alright
did you think I'd having those chicken
yeah no need to memories happier day the
two end up forming big romance and it's
a testament to the actors that this
whole relationship is pulled off because
Ethan Hawke's character on the surface
is not sympathetic at all but somehow
Ethan horse makes him very likeable and
you do feel pity for him
I guess you look towards the camera the
premise Lilith it's myelinated and it's
a testament to Sally Hawkins that she
plays such a fragile character that you
never feel pity for you can do much
better than me and everything I'll mark
with you have and it's a testament to
the director Aileen Walsh as well as the
screenwriters that this whole thing is
pulled off without being sentimental
it's an inspiring true story about using
art to overcome adversity you can see
Morty in limited theaters right now
and last but not least an interesting
film called the journey do I recognize
you from somewhere this is dr. Ian
Paisley leader of the Democratic
Unionist Party this is Martin McGuinness
from the Irish Republican Army
these men are panicky they are the
troubles on the surface this movie could
almost be a buddy comedy where you have
two people who are on opposite ends of
the spectrum who really don't like each
other and they're forced together and
they end up with stuttering that they
have more similarities and differences
it's based on real people but it's a
made-up version of what could have
happened it's actually a very
interesting look at politics at the end
of this either we hold a peaceful we go
back to war do you are nothing on your
conscience at all when we're mating a
civil war just like you are nothing like
me it does seem to tick off a lot of the
same beats as those buddy movies but I
found it really fascinating particularly
because it's a great showcase for the
actors you can see the journey in
limited theaters now this is our only
opportunity to build something double
ask
[Music]
we Ireland they have it full very
different films for you to watch this
weekend try to find the slapstick
romance lost in Paris this tearjerker
Megan Levy the sweet but not sentimental
Morty or the fascinating political drama
of the journey and as always let me know
what you've been watching what you're
looking forward to seeing I love to hear
from you I'm on Twitter at Alicia Malone
and I'll see you soon
bye
[Music]